I give another example of divine
intervention in 1984 I was in a plane
crash I don't swim crashed in the ocean
probably gets out every side of the
plane now staying on the wing with this
little wife dodo not around my neck and
it poet says jump jump under 200 oh and
I said I don't swim he says jump
undertow I said I'm glad I anyway it was
well I jump I forgot to tie it around my
waist I got on once twice third time
doughnuts here I take it put it around
my he says paddle away but the dog I do
like this and kicked my feet get a
hundred feet away the thing goes down to
the ocean right then on the wing I would
have died lady says boats planes boats
planes I think she's delusional because
before we die we just see cuz there's
blood in the water and there's minimal
the ocean you know checked herself twice
a year the Hawaii Fire Department sends
its emergency rescue teams out to do
emergency rescue exercises and all
different parts of the ocean this day
there were 1/2 nautical miles from where
the hell we crashed and they came and
saved us take the Vegas and get the
ultimate I'm in it I'm in the boat going
back to the shore in Hawaii I'm sitting
except pilot I'm saying
you saved my life you gave me
instructions on how to paddle away he
looks at me this guy's maybe six foot
four skinny pale Ichabod Crane looking
blue eyes I can see his face now black
here with white stripes in it I say
that's what I saw I just want to thank
you for saving my wife he said to me he
says I I appreciate you saying that to
me he says but I don't know who do you
pray to you know he says I'm a Catholic
so I hated God in Jesus he says but
don't thank me
whatever you pray to thank that and he
grabs my arm he looks at my face and he
starts crying like a baby
I didn't do that I didn't save myself I
didn't I don't have that kind of I don't
swim so something that I can't even
define said we're not finished with you
yet just got some things for you to do
go on and keep doing that's why I'm here
you